a dual policy u.s. citizen
I've been living here in Poland for
three years wonderful wonderful country
and hello okay and I'm working on the Z
ODB and I'm are we waiting to get
started or should i okay okay so today
I'll be speaking about Python links info
it's a discovery engine for the Python
web before you search the entire web
browse the curated web the problem is if
you do a regular search I'm you get two
hundred and three million results on
Python and that includes monty python
and snakes and SEO spam and all kinds of
junk and even if you just stick to the
good stuff
github Stack Overflow the blog
aggregator planet Python one or two
others up there you still have one and a
half million pages and there's still a
lot of junk in there you just want to
browse the curated web and how do you
want to organize it well for centuries
librarians have been organizing
information as taxonomy x' as trees of
information so that's what we do the
categories contain related content so if
you find the right category you find all
the all the good content on that topic
and did I create the taxonomy god no
it's way too big they're over two
hundred volunteers who've created who've
contributed contents to curated trees
what I do is I merge them into a single
tree I make sure that there's no more
than seven items in a particular
category and that's that's what creates
the tree that's what creates the
taxonomy and it's also a website so it's
a tree of categories containing links to
curated content and on the right hand
side you can see what the tree looks
like the indentation tells you where you
are here we have the page on markdown
there's an article reviewing the six
different markdown libraries and there's
a category for each markdown library and
within each category there can be
additional links here you can do a
search you'll see all the stuff for the
there's some junk what you do is you
click on the top-level category of
interest and then you just go back to
the previous page and your browse from
there
it also contains market information no
one cares about all this technical stuff
what they like is the market information
here is the map of companies in Warsaw
you can scroll down on the pit you can
click into the companies you can scroll
down on the page and you can see the
table of companies you can see click
into the company name you can see their
careers page their products you can get
their links here is the map for all of
Poland you can scroll down on the coal
of Poland page I think it's up to 82
companies now on the right hand sides it
tells you what they specialize in so you
can if you're outsourcing to Poland you
can find the company that does exactly
what it is that you want here is the oh
you can add your company just go to the
upper left ant corner had links had
company title is the name of your
company there's some fields to form in
fill in submit it if you want to make
your company look really good ever all
the recruiters they just want to put in
the careers page if you want to make
your company look really good add links
to your github your YouTube your Twitter
account products you have good reviews
of your company here's what the Nvidia
page looks like so you can see not only
all the links but there's a longer
description of all the links so if
somebody's looking at your company they
can decide which links they want to
follow on the right-hand side is it more
detailed description of the company here
we have the oh it's a JSON file if we
want to organize the Python web we need
a taxonomy and it's not a taxonomy that
one person uses everyone has to agree on
it so here's the JSON file it's a
taxonomy if you categorize your blog
postings on the right taxonomy it's
really easy to merge them all so
Creative Commons help yourself
here is an article by Wesley Chun in the
middle you see where it is in the
taxonomy and at the bottom you see the
keywords and you'll see that the
taxonomy location is really much more
descriptive there's a lot more
information in there than there is in
the keywords it's really fast it's all
done on Python on the server on the Z
ODB JavaScript on the client I download
the JSON the searches are instantaneous
at you have to slow it down for user
interfaces and of course roof pitch I'm
looking for people in Poland in England
so if you want to contact me
I have stickers here you can follow me
on Twitter
Python links you can go to my website
Python links info click on contact or
just to come talk to me and I'll be
handing out stickers in a moment thank
you very much thank you so much
you